(applause)
- And that's not the only cool thing
we have exclusively for Comic-Con,
this week we are broadcasting
our shows in virtual reality,
thanks to our good friends at AT&T.
That's right.
You can watch our show in VR,
via Conan Cardboard and other VR devices,
we have four Conan 360 cameras
placed all over this theater,
you can see the show from any angle.
It's pretty impressive, show 'em Andy!
- [Andy] All right, strapping in.
- All right.
(laughter)
- [Andy] All right, let's take it,
oh, hi Conan.
- Yeah, hey Andy, how's it going?
- [Andy] I see you got our,
oh, look at how big you look.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Andy] All right, let's
cycle through the cameras first
so people can see.
- [Conan] That's pretty impressive.
- [Andy] Yeah, yeah.
Okay, there it is.
Get a little vertigo going.
(audience applauds)
Whoa, oh yeah.
Now there's a good wave.
Hey buddy.
What's going on, pal?
(laughter)
Hey guy, how you doing?
- [Conan] Refuses to
acknowledge you in any way.
(audience laughs)
- [Andy] What's going on, buddy?
- [Conan] Nope, refuses to
acknowledge you in any way.
- [Andy] Yeah, yeah, hi friend.
- [Conan] Yeah.
- [Andy] What's your name, buddy?
- [Conan] Very nice.
(audience laughs)
Clearly someone is fleeing
the long arm of the law.
- [Andy] Someone's a little shy.
Wait, go back to the other
one because I want to get.
- [Conan] Oh, look at that!
(audience applauds)
- [Andy] Oh, there's me.
- [Conan] Wow.
Yeah.
- [Andy] I could lose a few.
(audience applauds)
Well, this is what you get to do at home.
Oh hi!
You brought your luggage.
(audience laughs)
- [Conan] Okay.
Andy you look like an idiot.
(laughs)
- [Andy] I do!
Oh my God, I just saw myself, I do!
- [Conan] Yeah,
it's as if you're in the
actual theater, Andy.
- [Andy] It really is.
(audience laughs)
It's so much more real
than actually being here.
- [Conan] Yeah, uh.
(audience laughs)
Now, those of you at home with headsets
can go to teamcoco.com/360
to experience all of this if you like.
Thanks for our friends at
AT&T for sponsoring Conan 360,
we're going to take a quick break,
when we come back,
the cast of Silicon Valley!
(audience applauds)
(big band music)